welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar Gama sir NIR
spectroscopy based solution as a
non-destructive method for rapid
accurate and affordable method for
cannabis potency analysis presented by
dr. Ronnie italic vice president of
research and compliance gamma sir my
name is Xavier Q tears and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Talley I will
now turn the presentation over there
hi hi everyone thank you lab rooms for
inviting me to speak today and thank you
for gamma start for letting me speak
today and share these slides with you
today so today I would like to talk to
you about potency testing and why
potency testing is so important and how
we solve several problems in potency
testing so what makes that we see
cannabis potency testing is so important
well first of all potency is critical
for ensuring safe and optimal use of
cannabis which means that especially a
medical user really needs to know what
he is consuming and if I would like to
buy my own cannabis flower I need to
know exactly what's in it and what am
intaking also today growers must grow
must send out their their ro for testing
which means that if I'm a grower and I
would I grow a few kilos I need to send
out a few flowers every time for potency
testing and that's how I am arks the
potency of my batch now actual the
actual monetary value of these flowers
are in fact set by the actual TSE and
CBD that the labs give back as the
results for these growers so for these
reasons accurate labeling in cannabis is
a must so just a small short little
quote by green camp news from September
12 2018 so labeling cannabis product
correctly is a huge importance
especially on the medical side of the
cannabis industry which is why miss
labeling these products can cause great
harm to users so what is the biggest
problem in potency testing the biggest
problem in potency testing is actually
miss labeling well since California has
required testing for the growers nearly
20% of cannabis products have failed
which means they have failed a plus
minus 10% accuracy between what is
written on the label of the box and
flowers actually inside in the first few
months of testing 11,000 flowers were
tested in 2002 thousand of them failed
some experts believe that the
differences between the labeling of the
flowers and what's actually inside the
box to be a difference of even up to 75%
and even more such extreme irregularity
unacceptable I'm safe and will and will
inevitably risk the growth of the
industry as regulated oversight
intensifies so how [ __ ] see dad's
thing done today well today potency
testing is done in the labs using HPLC
and as I said before the growers are
required to send out a few grams of
their grow each time and send it out to
the lab and in the HPLC technicians
Ramy samples and send out the THC and
CBD or other cannabinoids and turkeys
back to the labs before GC used to be
used as well but today we know that GC
is a bit less accurate because the GC
does not distinguish between the
carboxylated cannabinoids and the
non-commercial ativ can happen oiz so
for this reason today most of the labs
go to HPLC testing so what are the
challenges of that the industry faced
with potency testing and with using HPLC
well first of all the most the most
problematic problem of HPLC is that HPLC
testing is affected for a single flower
accuracy and not necessarily for the
whole past you must understand that when
HPLC is done for these flowers these
flowers are extracted grinded up
extracted and destroyed so the same
flower that was analyzed is not actually
the same flower that is later sold to
the customers and this is quite
problematic why is this so problematic
because cannabis has a very low
homogeneity or it's called a
heterogeneous CC because made in nature
it affects the way that the cannabis is
grown there's large hot the
non-homogeneity between the same flowers
from the same plants from the same euro
even in the same bag or in the same
container so this is problematic because
if we send out a few flowers it could be
that the flowers next to them are
completely different than the one that
were sent out for analyzing so what you
see in this slide is over 2,500 samples
which were plotted for the cannabinoids
content by percent of sample rates and
what you see here is total CBD or total
THC of these samples are most now in
blue you see total CBD and in green you
see total THC now these samples is 2,500
those that were dividing into their
strains which is what you see in our
x-axis let's look for instance at this
strain we can see that this strain was
it's the same strain which was measured
from different boxes from a certain
rower
you can see that the same strain used
flowers anywhere between 7 and 28% which
means that there's a huge difference
between the different flowers inside the
same from the solution where I've taken
out from the same plant and where were
in the stay bag are in the same
container that means that when a patient
wants to use one flower consume one
flower he can actual double dose what he
actually thinks that he's taking so why
is this happening because simply because
cannabis is a plant it's not a pill or a
capsule which is done in a pharma
company it's a plant in environmental
and environmental conditions affect the
growth of the plants and we can actually
compare it to grapes expecting all buds
within a container to be of the same
potency is like expecting grapes within
the bag to be the same ripeness we know
that when we want to eat some grapes one
grape could be a little bit sweeter and
the other people a little less sweeter
this is because the sugar content is not
evenly distributed among the among the
other grapes which is what happens
exactly with the cannabis the
cannabinoids are not evenly distributed
within the flower buds so the same plant
from the same grow in the same strain or
from different rows but all over the
plant it depends how how close the Sun
is and other environmental effects
affects the potency and the spread of
that molecules along the plants so again
this is problematic because if I send
out one flower this can be a completely
different flower than the flower that I
that I later sell so what is the way
that we could possibly be getting
labeling to be a bit more accurate well
one way we can do that is actually batch
more and send out more send out more for
testing but the problem with this is
that testing with HPLC in the labs takes
a long time and is very expensive and if
we send more and more samples out we
destroy our grow so this is quite
problematic another way to maybe get
better accurate and more accurate
labeling is to homogenize our cannabis
maybe take a few plans
a few flowers and homogenized them
together and send them out to the labs
but this is quite problematic because
once we grind up the cannabis flower the
monetary value of the flower to creases
by 50% the reason is that the cannabis
flower has many volatile molecules such
as terpenes and others and they start
coming out of the flower once we grind
up the flower also the trichomes can be
destroyed and then the protection of the
cannabinoids is destroyed and THC for
instance can start degrading its cbn so
the shelf life of the cannabis goes down
drastically so this is quite problematic
we tried just to homogenize the plants
and send them out like that we're
actually hurting the flood we're hurting
the flowers and we're taking we're
changing the experience of the user
another very very big problem the
potency testing and hplc testing is
facing today is rafet ability so we
petal is not achieving between the the
different labs probably most of you know
that samples can be sent out to
different labs and you can get different
answers so why is this happening first
of all there's no universal standard for
laboratory testing this means that each
lab has their own extraction method
their own HPLC method different
operators and different equipment and
instruments which means different labs
can give out different results another
very big problem is that the labs don't
like the share results with one another
because of competition and also because
cannabis for instance in the United
States it's still illegal so the labs do
not want to share the results with one
another what you see here in the figure
is one flower which was homogenized and
divided into five different samples and
sent out to five different labs you can
see a huge difference between the five
labs for instance greenleaf lab it shows
that this flower has thirteen point nine
percent THC and a contrary
MRX lab says it's twenty three point
nine percent that means that the same
flower gave a ten percent difference
between two different labs so very
problematic again the users do not know
what they're consuming the growers do
not know what they're growing and the
producers do not know what they're
buying another very big problem in this
industry and in the lab industry and
using HPLC is that some of the labs
liberally bump up the results in order
to satisfy customers so what you see
here are five different labs and the THC
content that they measured in the course
of two years now let's look in red and
red we can see one lab that has a
markedly higher THC than all the other
labs markedly higher than the other labs
this means that this lab is
intentionally bumping up its results and
this happens and it happens a lot in the
labs do it in order to to complete to
safe to have their competition because
it allows me to give out higher results
actually have more customers and allows
me to get money and they need paid
customers so if they gave out higher
results they have more customers which
means that many times the lab can give
out results like 30% 31% and these are
incorrect most of the flowers do not
reach such high contents but some of the
labs have figured out how to save their
customers and they deliberately bump up
their prices and there are BAC or CBD
contents another issue in the cannabis
that potency testing industry is that
testing is currently costly slow and
inconsistent we talked about
inconsistent but let's talk about costly
and slow well a single test can cost
between 80 and 300 dollars for just one
single test which is quite problematic
because if you'd like to send out many
tests this will cost a lab a lot of
money also testing is very slow not only
is the process of testing slow but the
labs are booked up and the popular labs
are even more booked up and this results
in the fact that some of the growers can
wait for maybe three weeks to a month in
order to get results very problematic
because they grow and they'd like to
know what's going on and what they they
have grown and they are waiting about a
month to get their results so some other
disadvantages of using HPLC for potency
testing well first of all we talked
about the fact that the testing cost a
lot of money the reason for this is
first of all that in order to do these
testing large and very expensive
equipments but must be bought by the
laughs HPLC or GC can cost anywhere
between ten to a hundred thousand
dollars very very expensive also very
trained technician or analytical
chemists need to be hired in order
to do these to do these tests and in
order to perform a test and also
interpret the test so also a lot of
money another problem is that hazardous
solvents and sample and disposables are
used up in the process which means it's
a very non green and also as I said
before some of the labs take three weeks
a month to give back samples but just
for one sample in the lab itself can
take anywhere between thirty minutes to
45 minutes just for one HPLC sample
which means that the labs don't do the
people they could do but they don't do
much repeat testing because each test
takes a long time and as I said before
the biggest problem is the sample is
destroyed and the same flower that was
tested does not go back in a so later
so we at gamma stirred have been touring
we are we are based in Israel that we've
been touring all over the world and
we've been to Canada in the United
States and Europe and all over and we've
talked to all the players along the
supply chains and these are some quotes
that we have gotten from different
players along the cannabis supply chain
so a California dispensary owner told us
how do I know that flower I bought are
really worth the premium I have no
reliable means to validate potency on
the spot a cannabis grower told us I'm
tired of spending hundreds of dollars
potency testing I needed in-house
solution and a medical cannabis user
told us I never noticed the flower i buy
are right for me sometimes they cause me
anxiety and sometimes I can't fall
asleep so this is something we've heard
a lot we've heard many users that don't
trust cannabis and try to use cannabis
and have left the and are not using
cannabis anymore because they they open
it back and they consume one flower and
what time it makes them feel very very
very well and the next time it doesn't
work on them and the last time and the
third time it gives some anxiety attacks
so this is quite problematic because
they don't trust the medicine and then
the doctors don't trust the medicine and
they don't want to use it anymore so the
industry has been looking for a
different way to do potency testing to
go to them maybe in different ways today
that the industry can potency test on
the spot
and so I would like to speak to you a
little bit about what near spectroscopy
is and how it's used in a cannabis
business and exactly what we do so what
is New Year or near IR spectroscopy so
near IR near-infrared spectroscopy is
its aspect response Copic form of
testing it uses light spectrum to assess
the chemical content of a test object
simply a near IR or near infrared light
is shined upon the specimens and the
molecules inside absorb some of the
light and then the light that is
absorbed out of the specimen is actually
linear too it gives us information it is
linear to the concentration of molecules
that we have inside specimens what's
very good about this this method is not
destructive and you can use the for
instance a flower or or other specimens
in its raw form you don't have to grind
it or do any extraction and for this
reason high-dollar crop in in not even
in the cannabis industry but in other
crop industry use this technique for
online testing it's quite valuable it's
quite easy and as I said again it's
non-destructive and also the
pharmaceutical industry is also adopted
near IR spectroscopy based solutions so
for this reason much of the industry
much of the food industry and the drug
administration industry has turned to
near IR and this is something that we
did not invent it for many years in the
industry so one thing that's quite
important to understand about near IR is
book when we're looking at one specific
test and we compare a near IR to
chromatography or HPLC near IR is not as
precise chromatography and when we look
at tested one test one test they will
always be less accurate than HPLC this
is because near IR s estimation an HPLC
is chromatography yet nearly aren't
quite appropriate for many applications
especially for expensive crops because
we can test them and not not destroy
them for this reason the US Food and
Drug Administration has approved er ER
for medical procedures from a suitable
testing and also for food testing so
near IR Poznan
genius crop analysis by averaging
several results in multiple sampling on
a sample so Sierra our test takes only
about 60 seconds per test rather than 30
to 45 minutes we can use what is called
the collate and average approach which
means we could take several tests on
what specimens and then average them out
so if we have a specimen that is
non-homogeneous
we can actually take several several
tests on one sample and average them out
together so a bit of advantages of near
IR register HPLC so near-infrared
spectroscopy testing requires only 60
seconds - just a few minutes near IR
spectroscopy equipment can be operated
by moderately trained technicians
near IR creates less overhead expenses
as I've said before you don't need any
sample preparation or to use any
solvents or any plastics near IR
produces no hazardous waste solvents it
requires no ongoing expense budget for
consumable lab supplies and nearly is
the high value cannabis samples intact
on the contrary HPLC testing requires
just 30 to 45 minutes per test HPLC must
be operated by highly skilled and highly
paid technicians HPLC requires large
overhead expenses HPLC produces
hazardous waste solvents and consumes
disposable equipment and as I've
mentioned several times HPLC that
destroys the sample that's tested so
when we talk about financial
consideration of course in the IR has
much a financial consideration over HPLC
because no sample is destroyed there's
no use of solvents and no skill two
conditions are needed so what are the
drawbacks of the Ariane so as I've said
before near-ir is not a society's permit
ography
for any single test HPLC is always gonna
be more accurate but when we start
analyzing batches and we like to test
more than one sample now a URI can be
better and more accurate than HPLC key
we can test much more because we don't
destroy anything and it takes much less
time also the
one of the ones the facts about near-ir
is that the near-ir does not work on its
own near-ir needs in order to quantify
results at potency for instance for
cannabis we must we must work against a
goals high gold standard our gold
standard here is the HPLC so for
chemical quantification to reach HPLC
accuracy multiple calibrations and
correlations are needed the greater the
number of correlations against HPLC the
better than they are IR results another
problem with near IR is that mario's
doesn't always penetrate into the sample
this absolutely actually risks the fact
that we're actually measuring only the
surface area for instance of the flower
bud and not the inside of the flower bud
today there in the market there are
several canada specific knee area
yeah there are near IR spectroscopy
units in the market already but they
have no they do not have sufficient
correlation with HPLC and they're not
accurate for several reasons first of
all they don't have a very extensive
database so as I said before a near IR
must work against some sort of a gold
standard so we the near IR estimates
according to what the HPLC results give
you so you can think of it as an as a
graph with the y-axis you get your you
capture your near IR spectrum your near
IR spectrum and then the x-axis you get
your HPLC your real reading and you can
using data science machine learning you
can make correlation line between the
both and the more the correlated is in
the tighter your your line is your
accuracy gets much better so also the
largest your data but the larger your
data base is that also gives you more
accurate results so this is the problem
with them with cannabis specific units
in the market today also all the units
that are in the market today ask you to
sample prep or grind up your flour maybe
take a small sample out of the flour and
this is quite problematic because
cannabis not only is non homogeneous is
not homogeneous when we look at
different flours from the same plants
but the flower itself is not homogeneous
which means that the active molecules
in the flowerbed itself are not evenly
dispersed on the flower which means
there are areas with higher THC and CBD
markings and there's areas with lower
THC and CBD markings and this is
problematic because if you just use
near-ir
or we take just sample the flower we
might get a different reading than what
the average flower really gives out so
what you see here is some some analysis
we did in the lab what you see here are
a few flowers that we analyzed we
grinded up these flowers and we took
different areas of the flower we divided
these flowers into three to five
different specimens samples according to
the size of flower and we ran them an
HPLC and we looked at the category a
cannabinoid content of these flowers or
it THC content and CD contents you can
see that they are very much
spread out which means that we don't
have the exact same content in every
place along the flower for infants if we
look here we can see that this same
plant can be anywhere between 17 to 27
percent in the same flower
okay sorry 19 to 27 percent THC in the
same flower which means different areas
of the flower have different
cannabinoids content quite problematic
because when we if you want to just use
near IR and we point the near IAC's of
different areas the flower we might get
different results another analysis that
we did in our lab is this visual
analysis well but what I wrote here is
that all trichomes are not spread equal
well we know that 99% of the active
material in cannabis are stored in these
granular composites called trichomes and
these trichomes are not even Li's a
spread along the cannabis flower on the
two the two left pictures you can see
the pictures of a flap of two different
flowers sorry two different areas on
flower and on the right you can see a
heat images of these flowers which look
at the trichome density along the flower
what you see in yellow and in green is
high trichrome density areas in which
you see in blue and in light blue is low
trichome density areas which means that
the tribe
are not spread equal so the THC CBD and
all the active materials are not spread
equal along the flower so using the IR
alone is quite problematic for this
reason we have created the gamma start
which is the optimal solution and this
is already here already selling our
machine all over North America Europe
and in Europe this is how the machine
looks and it's operated using a
smartphone with an application via
bluetooth which connects to the set to
the gamma start machine so this is the
first non struct of portable and
activist cannabis analyzer what's very
interesting about this machine is that
you don't have to do any sample
preparation and it's not destructive the
flower goes in as hole and comes back
out as a whole flower you don't have to
do anything to it you simply place it in
activate the Machine and you get your
you're reading these readings are quite
reliable it's real-time decision-making
and fast and easy to use
quite simple using an application on
your phone and there's no uh and it's
free of all toxic chemicals so how does
the gamma start work well the gamma cert
employs three different technologies
inside of it the first technology that I
spoke to you about is the near-infrared
spectroscopy okay and as I said before
we use the callate an average of pouch
which means we take several spectrums or
take several spectrum images of the
flower seconds we use computer vision
algorithms as I as I showed you before
this heat map inside the gamma cert we
also have a small RGB camera the camera
takes several images of the flower and
we do visual analysis on the on the
flower what do we do first of all we
look at different trichome density along
the flower and we can smartly tell the
near IR where to sample from also the
camera is quite important because the
distance of the near IR to the flower is
very very important which means that if
the near IR is too close to the flower
or too far from the flower we lose much
of the information so each time the
distance has to be set and this is
locked by the by the camera also we want
to make sure that the near IR since this
is a
close the sheep we want to make sure
that the near IR is always on the flower
for accurate meaning the last technology
that's combined in our machine is a
machine learning so we use algorithms as
I've explained to you before we do
algorithms to correlate between near IR
spectroscopy and HPLC readings and we do
advanced machine learning algorithms in
order to get a plus minus 10 percent
accuracy and to do this whole testing in
one to three minutes another very
important factor in the gamma stir
machine is what you see here on the top
is this gold-plated reflector this is
quite important this reflector it sits
in the back of the flower and without it
you you don't you lose much of the
information the way that it acts and the
reason that it's so important is that
the light beams to the flower and the
flower itself is not rock solid and it's
got holes in it it stars so the light
goes through the flower which makes and
replicate and go and hits the reflector
in the back so first of all since the
the light goes through the flower and
the flower has holes inside the near-ir
to see areas inside the flower and not
just only on the surface area which is
one of the drawbacks of near-ir also
when the light goes through the flower
it goes to the reflector the reflector
acts like a mirror the light reflects on
different areas on the reflector and
then back on to the flower and like a
mirror and each in each of spectral
analysis that we get from one point of
the flower is not just a small little
area on the flower but rather a mix of
different areas which replicated from
the reflector to the flower now we take
several specters of one flower which in
each spectra is an average of several of
different areas along the flower because
the reflector acts like a mirror in the
background also the reflectors strongly
amplifies our near IR signal so simply
how it works I'd like to show you how
simple it is you simply have to slide in
the reflector as you see an image one in
image two that reflector locks into the
machine using a magnet on the side of
the machine then you take out a small
piece
which is inside the machine you can see
it in image form on the top of the
machine there's a green circle which is
a metal and which and the pin is
connected to it you simply put the
flower you insert the flower into this
pin take the pin with the flower and in
the top of the of the drop of the drawer
and there's a magnet the metal green
parts of the pin back the magnets into
the magnet and sticks in and then you
just close the Machine activate it and
press analyze on the machine wait about
three to four minutes and you get your
results what we measure its total THC
and total CBD just a small little
explanation also about the calibration
so if you can see on image six at the
bottom of this container at the bottom
part of the below the reflector there's
a small little square that's the color
right this is an ultimate of spectral on
an ultimate white when the Machine
starts working what happens is that the
near-ir first goes to this ultimate
white and take several spectrums of this
white this all is done and goes up to
our cloud where our database is stored
and all the algorithms are stored now we
know what the what the exact reading of
this white should be and if we get
incorrect readings we can see this
because we we're always connected to our
cloud and then we get a warning
something went wrong and also the user
gets a warning something went wrong this
way we know that if you don't get a
warning that the near-ir is fine and
it's in tune and that the near end that
the white is in place and that the near
IR is working correctly after that the
camera takes several images of the
flower tells the near IR where to sample
from but before that the near IR goes to
the flower takes several spectrum
analysis of the flower in order to get
to a specific spectrum which doesn't
move which means we want to get to a
specific temperature where all the
spectrums are superimposed one on top of
another at this point the the near IR
spectrometer goes back down self
calibrates itself once more goes back up
to the flower
does the whole callate and average
method which means it takes several
specimens on the several spectrum sorry
on the flower all these spectrums are
sent up to our cloud where we have 4000
flower database with our algorithms the
algorithms are done there and then your
answer goes right back down to your
phone and you get your total THC and
your total CBD readings quite simple you
don't need any analytical chemist or a
trained technician to use it you simply
have a few buttons on your phone and you
press it it takes three to four minutes
with a plus minus 10 percent accuracy
reading which means that a 20 percent
flower can come in anywhere between 18
to 22 percent so just to sum up over
thousands of flowers and growing
correlated with HPLC results the gamma
star has far suppressed the datapoint
libraries of other candidates specific
near our testers it is the world's
largest database of cannabis spectral
images each multiple measurement gamma
star performs during the single test has
industry-leading accuracy cloud based
software analyzes results to identify
any outlaying data which means that if
you enter something that's not a
cannabis flower you would get an error
okay so you can't just put whatever you
like inside you would get an error
reading the software analyzes its own
analysis for constant improvements of
accuracy then the test results and data
is made available to the user via
smartphone or laptop and of course you
can extrapolate it to excel and work on
the results and do whatever you would
like with these results you can also add
you have the option to add your variety
or your strain whatever you would like
to write about the specific flower that
was tested so by combining leading-edge
near-ir methodology the visual image
analysis expensive data science and the
sheen learning chemistry provides
testing solution that's more than the
sum of its parts
thank you very much for listening to me
thank you dr. Talley for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank Leopards for making
today's educational webcast possible and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2009
tea
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted me email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
goodbye